si los anuncios realizados por el
consejo nacional electoral ha sido en
principio ha informado que ha sido
notificado formalmente luego de la
aplicación de la muerte Cruzada por
parte del decreto siete cuatro uno que
contempla la realización de elecciones
generadas anticipadas en este sentido la
presidenta de la asamblea del Consejo
Nacional electoral ha dado algunas
informaciones tienen siete días para
convocar a elecciones esto puede ser
hasta el 24 de mayo o antes en este
sentido también ha dicho que realizará
un manual específico para llevar a cabo
estas elecciones dado que son inéditas
en el país no se contemplaría la
realización de una segunda vuelta
electoral dado que no habría tiempo para
realizarla yo deben garantizar unas
elecciones en los próximos 90 días
contemplando así las relaciones de El
cronograma electoral
llámese así las campañas electorales los
debates las impugnaciones electorales De
igual forma también dicho que no se
conoce todavía Cuál será el presupuesto
para realizar así las elecciones
De igual forma también ha dicho que el
presidente de la república no está
impedido de lanzarse como candidato
inclusive ya se conocen algunos en
nombres que podrían ser posibles
candidatos a elecciones generales
elecciones presidenciales recordemos que
en Ecuador se van a realizar tanto las
elecciones presidenciales como las
elecciones legislativas luego de que el
presidente de la república disolviera la
asamblea nacional hoy parecen hacer ex
asambleístas De igual forma también ha
dicho que no se contempla la inscripción
de nuevos movimientos y partidos
políticos dado que no habría tiempo para
en realizar este
esta inscripción de nuevos partidos
políticos Rodrigo y Gustavo que otros
sectores se han pronunciado también tras
la decisión de lasso Qué ambiente además
se respira y en Ecuador
bueno tras la decisión de lazo decretado
la mañana del día de hoy han llovido las
cascadas reacciones en este país en
principio la conai ha sido uno de los
principales sectores que se ha declarado
en resistencia y De igual forma ha
llamado a convocar asambleas permanentes
y ha llamado a su Consejo Político para
evaluar Cuál va a ser la gestión del
presidente de la república recordemos
que ahora el presidente de la república
va a gobernar bajo decreto y ellos han
dicho que se mantendrán vigilantes
porque ellos califican que esta
declaratoria de la muerte Cruzada es un
autogolpe para evadir así el juicio
político recordemos que tan solo el día
de hoy iba a iniciarse la segunda fase
de este juicio político y la votación
sería también el próximo sábado han
llamado a la resistencia han dicho que
inclusive las bases han llamado a la
movilizaciones en las calles pero se ha
dicho que se mantendrá muy muy cauto han
habido reacciones también de sectores
políticos que apoyan o rechazan esta
decisión y han habido también reacciones
internacionales inclusive desde la Casa
Blanca el representante de la casa
Blanca el secretario de estado ha dicho
que las relaciones con Ecuador son
fuertes y que se mantengan trabajando
con este país